right now ladies and gentlemen I'd like
to introduce one of the film's great
comedic artists but unfortunately he
couldn't be here tonight so instead
please welcome a very good friend and a
very funny man mr. Steve Martin
thank you
very much we were going to go live from
Malaysia but the TV crew was hanged at
the airport
what Billy didn't mention when he opened
the show was that before the show could
be broadcast to Russia this year there
had to be an international agreement
that there would be no opening
production number they figured it took a
long time to get the iron curtain to
rise and they didn't want to take any
chances on having it come back down
again right I'm here to present the the
Oscar for Best Original Score which I'm
surprised to find out it's a music
category
this year's Oscar orchestra is conducted
by Academy Award winner bill Conti
now the five nominees for original score
mr. Conti
john williams for born on the 4th of
July
David Grusin for The Fabulous Baker boys
James Horner for field three
John Williams for Indiana Jones and the
Last Crusade
Alan Menken for The Little Mermaid
and the Oscar goes to Alan Menken for
the Little Mermaid
first of all I'd like to thank my
collaborator Howard Ashman
who encouraged me to take the
opportunity to compose my first film
score with a little mermaid thank you
for your support Howard I'd like to
thank all the people at Disney Jeffrey
Katzenberg Roy Disney Peter Schneider
and Maureen Donnelly are outstanding
directors John Musker Ron Clements and
thanks to a great music department
Marcus Rader Thomas has a cherry in dr.
Jack Redford music editor Cathy Bennet
recording engineer John Richards
supervisors Chris Montana and Andy Hill
special thanks by Manito Scott shupette
my wife Janice and Academy members thank
you
you